Сім років тому він і уявити не міг, що колись замість зброї триматиме в руках тісто.
Михайло - ветеран російсько-української війни.
А віднедавна - засновник піцерії "Pizza BRO" у Києві, де він - заодно і шеф-кухар.
Ніколи я не робив взагалі щось, що стосується готування.
В принципі досвіду не було.
З 2014 по 2016 рік Михайло служив у зоні АТО.
Найгарячішими, згадує, були бої біля Попасної.
Саме звідти він привіз усі ці прапори з підписами батальйону та фото з побратимами,
які нині - почесно прикрашають стіни його власної піцерії.
Ветеран каже: війна назавжди змінила його, а період після демобілізації був особливо непростим.
Дуже тяжко хлопцям, які повертаються, у яких не було постійної роботи до війни,
дуже часто стикалися з таким, що під час повернення не могли знайти роботу.
Приходили на роботу влаштовуватись і тільки й чули: "А! Атошник! Брати не будемо!"
Важко було. І адаптуватися. Підтримували, як могли.
Я ніби заново закохалася в нього з цією підтримкою!
Після довгої адаптації до цивільного життя Михайло зрозумів: хоче заснувати власну справу.
І таку, яка надихатиме інших ветеранів та буде допомагати і їм почати нове життя після служби.
Саме тому у піцерію "Pizza BRO" Михайло запрошує навчатися кулінарії
і працювати таких, як він сам - ветеранів.
І каже: попит на вакансії серед чинних захисників уже є.
Працевлаштовуємо ветеранів, якщо є можливість, якщо ветеран має бажання працювати,
є медична довідка, то він буде працевлаштований.
Він буде спілкуватися з ветеранами в закладі.
Я є ветеран, я будь-якого ветерана розумію, через що він пройшов.
Частину прибутку свого закладу Михайло передає на ЗСУ.
Каже: допомагати армії після демобілізації було мрією довгі роки.
Реалізувати проєкт - орендувати приміщення та закупити обладнання -
вдалося за допомогою гранту, який Михайло виграв у конкурсі бізнес-проєктів
від Українського ветеранського фонду, заснованого урядом.
Я от думав, як відкрити? Як це все буде?
Особливо, коли був початок, коли ми прийшли в це приміщення, зрозуміли, що роботи багато.
Вдалося! Нам вдалося!
Вийшло здійснити мрію про власний проєкт і у ветерана Дениса.
Хоча, ще в березні 2022 року він, досвідчений військовий, був на полі бою
і звільняв Київщину від окупантів під час повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну.
Бої були безперестанку. Оцей крайній бій, де я отримав поранення, був 7 годин.
Було важко, тут дуже було багато смерті.
Відчуття провини було перед тими, хто загинув… Так, як у всіх.
Сьогодні - вже після звільнення зі служби - ветеран допомагає таким, як він,
повертатися до колишнього життя - під час сеансів адаптаційних розмов.
Дуже хороша вправа, яка допомагає зупинити думки негативні.
Уявляєте перед очима екран, на якому відбиваються думки негативні.
Це хаб психологічної допомоги в Ірпені "Танто".
У його команді декілька кваліфікованих психологів,
які проводять безкоштовні сеанси з військовослужбовцями.
Денис планував створити подібний центр реабілітації ще у 2014-му, коли вперше повернувся з фронту на Донеччині.
Там він отримав контузію. Пізніше - після такої ж травми та поранення у 2022-му не вагався:
якщо лишиться живим після тяжких боїв, почне надавати іншим ту допомогу, якої оперативно не отримав свого часу.
Йшла війна, а система реабілітації наша… Її, по суті, не було.
Настільки в умовах цієї війни така велика кількість людей, яка потребує допомоги,
що державна система не в змозі впоратися з цим всім.
Я займаюся першою психологічною допомогою.
Довіряють, відкриваються, тому що я пройшов це, вони знають, про що я говорю.
В мене є позитивний досвід у відновленні.
Кошти на заснування хабу - понад 600 тисяч гривень - Денис отримав, як і інші ветерани,
які звернулися минулого року до урядового фонду і пройшли відбір на грант.
Вони досить швидко набирають оборотів і досить швидко починають уже допомагати іншим.
Вчора йому самому була потрібна допомога,
а через тиждень він уже починає допомагати своїм побратимам, дітям своїх побратимів.
За період повномасштабної війни в Україні за рахунок коштів з державного бюджету
вдалося підтримати понад 200 бізнес-проєктів ветеранів,
розповідають в Українському ветеранському фонді.
Цьогоріч на фінансування таких ініціатив виділено близько 170 мільйонів гривень.
Кількість заявок від ветеранів за останні місяці зросла в рази,
втім фінансово допомогти вдається лише тим, хто пройшов конкурс із наданням необхідної документації -
статусу учасника бойових дій та реєстрації підприємства з попередньою юридичною перевіркою.
Така можливість є навіть у тих, хто ще нині досі перебуває на службі.
Серед чинних захисників на фронті, за даними опитування,
вже сьогодні 64 відсотки хочуть заснувати власну справу після повернення з передової.
Серед ветеранів, які наразі не змогли через ті або інші причини піти захищати свої країну,
28 відсотків шукають роботу і не можуть знайти.
Логічний наслідок, чому люди починають займатися своєю справою,
тому що це люди, які не звикли здаватися.
Практика державної підтримки підприємств ветеранів поширена закордоном,
зокрема у США, Великій Британії та країнах ЄС.
Там держава регулярно співпрацює з таким бізнесом та замовляє в нього послуги чи товари.
В Україні наразі це неможливо, пояснюють у ветеранському фонді -
оскільки законодавчо у нас не закріплене поняття ветеранського підприємництва.
Від цього всі біди. Ми не можемо говорити ні про якісь податкові преференції
і загалом, що таке саме ветеранське підприємництво.
Уже більше року лежить законопроєкт у профільному комітеті про ветеранське підприємництво, про саме визначення.
Попри це, в умовах війни на поміч проєктам ветеранів уже приходять й іноземні партнери.
Так залучити інвестиції до свого бізнесу вдалося Віталію - колишньому військовому із зони АТО,
який заснував першу в Україні приватну школу саперів для цивільних.
За кошти благодійної організації з гуманітарного розмінування HALO Trust
вдалося найняти на роботу перших інструкторів з демінування - таких же ветеранів, як сам Віталій.
А ще - підготувати перші пів сотні майбутніх інструкторів
і саперів для роботи в складі міжнародної групи демінерів.
Зараз ми уже проводимо навчання їхньої другої групи інструкторів.
Ті, які готуються від HALO Trust, вони працюють в складі гуманітарного розмінування HALO Trust.
А навчають колишні військові, теж ветерани.
Випускники школи Віталія вже займаються гуманітарними розмінуваннями на Київщині, Житомирщині та Харківщині.
Сам Віталій певен: за потрібного фінансування соціально направлені бізнес-проєкти
ветеранів вже зараз зможуть допомогти Україні подолати наслідки війни в різних сферах.
Його місія - підтримувати розмінування довгі роки.
Людський ресурс саме з цивільних - чому?
Тому що зараз війна іде і військові займаються військовою справою.
ДСНС просто не вистачає особового складу.
Зараз активно шукаємо фінансування для того, щоб збільшити ліцензійний обсяг підготовки.
Знайдемо, збільшимо ліцензований обсяг підготовки - спочатку до ста осіб, тоді і двохсот.
Проблема тільки у фінансуванні.
Смачного, хлопці!
Дуже смачно! Домашня атмосфера виходить!
У піцерії Михайла - справи від початку йдуть добре, щодня нові відвідувачі,
але незмінно - сюди регулярно приходять ветерани та чинні військовослужбовці.
У тому, аби наші захисники завжди почували себе тут, як вдома, чоловік бачить свою місію.
Уже є постійні клієнти. Ті хлопці, які пройшли війну, вони справляться з тим, що в тилу. Тут є майбутнє.
Тут можна працювати як на себе, так і на когось.
Він знайшов себе! Йому подобається те, що він робить, він росте над собою,
старається і робить такі речі, яких від себе не очікував!
Михайло впевнений: в Україні з’явиться ще безліч бізнес-проєктів від нинішніх захисників,
які після перемоги повернуться до цивільного життя.
А він обіцяє: підтримати кожного з тих, хто проситиме його допомогти.